hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
yes that's right today the langfocus
channel has reached 50 000 subscribers
this is a big day for me
when i started my channel i always had
the dream in mind the goal in mind of
reaching
50 000 subscribers and i thought that
was kind of the pinnacle
now it seems like that's an achievable
goal and we'll see how much further i
can get than 50 000 but for now
i've achieved my initial goal and that's
really great really exciting for me so
thank you for
all of your support so on to today's
topic
imagine that there was a mysterious
language in europe that was surrounded
on all sides by languages that it had
absolutely no connection with
well there actually is a language like
that the language is the
basque language
basque is a language isolate meaning
that it has no known connection to any
other language
it's located in europe but it's not an
indo-european language
it forms its own language family and it
is quite distinct
very different from indo-european
languages it is spoken by the basque
people in the basque country a region
that spans the spain france border in
the westernmost perennials mountains
it is not spoken by all basques but by
around 27
of them in the basque country overall
the number of native speakers is
714 135 out of a total population of 2
million 648
998 and that includes about 663 000 on
the spanish side and 51
100 on the french side it is an official
language at the regional level in spain
in the basque autonomous community
and in navarre in france it holds no
official status
the origins of the basque language are
shrouded in mystery as i said before it
is a language isolate
it is thought to be the last remaining
language that existed in europe before
the arrival of the indo-european
languages
there is conclusive evidence that basque
is a descendant of the aquitanian
language which is an ancient language
spoken in the perennials region
some similarities are known between
aquitanian and the ancient iberian
language so some people think that they
might be related
but those similarities might just be due
to geographic proximity and mutual
influence we don't know some linguists
suggest that aquitanian was part of a
wider language family called the
vasconic languages which covered most of
europe
before the arrival of the indo-european
languages but again
we don't know other people draw a
connection between basque and other
non-indo-european languages like the
caucasian languages but again
that's right we don't know one thing we
do know is that the basque people who
descend mostly from farmers who arrived
in the area around 6 000 years ago
were isolated from the outside world for
thousands of years that's probably
partly because of the basque country's
forested mountain terrain
and its lack of tempting resources that
prevented invasion
this isolation is probably what allowed
their language to survive and develop
into the basque language of today
of course there were latin borrowings
into the language and there have been
other romance language borrowings
throughout the centuries
but nothing like the total disappearance
of other pre-latin languages in that
area
basque was a unified language until the
middle ages when it began to diverge
into dialects because of administrative
and political divisions within the
basque country
despite being ruled by outside regimes
throughout the centuries the basque
country
still remained isolated and relatively
uninfluenced by the outside world and
that includes the language
but when francisco franco became ruler
of spain in 1939
the use of basque was heavily suppressed
because franco wanted to assimilate all
of spain into castilian culture
it was forbidden to speak basque in
schools and in public it was banned from
media and removed from public services
this led to a big reduction in the
number of people who could speak the
basque language and that's part
of the reason that only 27 percent of
people in the basque country speak the
language today
in the 1960s that suppression was eased
somewhat and basque language schools
became permitted and the language began
being used in publications and in
education again
this led to the creation of a
standardized language called yushkara
batua
it was developed by the basque language
academy or the yuskal zendiya and it was
intended to be comprehensible to
speakers of the various dialects of
basque there are five main basque
dialects
biscayan or western basque kipuskowan or
central basque
upper navarees navaris la purdian and
sulitan
in france these dialects correspond with
the historic provinces of the basque
country but they don't completely
correspond with
the modern provinces of today the level
of intelligibility depends on the
distance between those two dialects on
the dialect continuum with the most
distant dialects having trouble
understanding each other but that's
where the standard language yushkara
batua comes in so
what is the basque language like well
its vocabulary has been influenced by
the surrounding romance languages to
some extent but when you look at its
structure you will see that it is
unlike any romance language or like any
indo-european language for that matter
basque has grammatical cases
12 cases to be exact but that is not
really unusual in indo-european
languages
but it has something called the ergative
case that means that there's a special
form of the noun when it's the subject
of a sentence and it takes a transitive
verb that means it has a direct
object this ergative case is marked with
a k at the end of the noun
now along with the ergative case there
is also something called the absolutive
case
this is for subjects of intransitive
verbs meaning that it has no direct
object
and in this case there is no ending on
the end of the noun well let's take a
look at a couple of sentences
that means the child fell in the street
but if we look at it word by word you
can see the interesting structure of
basque word by word it's
child the street the in fall
is if we look at the first word there
ume is child but then
the definite article is the a at the end
then for the next word kalayan kale
is street and then the definite article
is a and then
in is the n at the end of the word if we
look at the next word erodi that's a
verb meaning fall but it's in the
perfect
aspect that means that it shows a
completed action and then the auxiliary
verb comes after the main verb at the
end
and this one means is it's the present
tense form of to be
and another sentence
that means the man has given the book to
the child so word by word
man the and then ergative case child
the dative case book the given
has the first word is gizonak gizon is
man then the definite article is a and
then the ergative case
is kei umayari that's child again child
is ume
and then this time it has the definite
article a and then it has the dative
case marker
the at the end the dative case basically
shows who or what is being affected by
the action
the next word dibudua the buru is book
and then ah is the definite article and
this one looks like a loan word from a
romance language
the next word iman is a verb and it's in
the perfect aspect showing that the
action is completed
and then the auxiliary verb dio comes
after and that means
has and the next sentence
that means the woman has seen the man so
word by word
woman the ergative case man the
sin has so the first word emakumeak
is woman that is the a and
ergative case is decay the next word
gizona that's the man
and the definite article again the next
word is ikushi which means seen and
again that's a verb with the perfect
aspect showing the actions completed and
then the auxiliary verb comes at the end
and it means has as you can see the
basque language is very different from
any
indo-european language very different
from any language that i've studied
but it also looks quite logical and
systematic it would be a shame to lose a
language that's so unique and that
connects us with the ancient history of
europe
the number of basque speakers has
sharply declined over the last century
but there are efforts in spain to revive
the language and to make it more
widespread again
and hopefully such efforts will continue
and become more prominent in france as
well
thank you for watching the langfocus
channel i want to say thanks again to
all of my patreon supporters you guys
are awesome i appreciate you
thanks to all those other people who
volunteered in different ways by
creating subtitles for videos or
offering to write some scripts for
geofocus or
all of those things also be sure to
check out the langfocus facebook account
twitter account and instagram because
i'm often on there and that's a way to
keep in touch and always know
when i have new content being released
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
you